so in recent weeks the allies have come
together to try and look at ways that
they can reduce the timelines
surrounding the process there are a
number of steps involved there's
something called the accession protocol
which all allies have to sign here at
nato and the two new members would sign
that as well in order to get to that
signature we'll have to go through
something called the accession talks
once the protocol is actually signed
then every member of the alliance has to
ratify the agreement which can take some
time and you're right in the past we've
seen instances where that process has
taken upwards of a year but given the
situation on the ground in ukraine the
fact that we have a war that's ongoing
on european territory i think all allies
are in agreement that this process needs
to be expedited so ambassador just be
clear you're hoping to get this achieved
in the coming months so what by the
summer by the end of the year
ideally i think we'd like to see it done
in a couple of months that's the goal
obviously the white house is clearly
minded to approve uh this application
anyone can ask to join but of course the
members of nato have to agree it turkey
is a stumbling block isn't it it's said
it is opposed the white house said this
week it's confident consensus can be
reached can you explain to us what's
going on and why the white house is
confident of that has president biden
been in bilateral talks well first and
foremost let me say yes there has been
an ally turkey that has come forward to
express some concerns they have specific
security concerns that they've raised
with all of the allies here at nato
headquarters and we're all taking those
concerns very seriously i think the
reason you see the confidence stemming
out of the white house and in fact many
other capitals across europe and here at
nato headquarters is simply because the
strength of the alliance really rests on
our ability to continually bring forward
disagreements debates
alternative points of view and work
through those disagreements to reach
consensus everything that nato does
has to be reached through consensus you
have to have 30 allies vote on it so we
have 73 years of experience of working
through allied differences and for that
reason i too personally am quite
confident that we'll find a way through
this just be clear then you don't think
in the end turkey will be the block
i think we will see eventually sweden
and finland joining the alliance in the
not too distant future